the fashion backlash in Japan there's an
outcry on social media after a number of
Japanese companies reportedly banned
female employees from wearing eyeglasses
to work
some women are calling the workplace
rules discriminatory and outdated and it
doesn't end with eyeglasses as Lucy
craft reports the controversy is quite
similar to another concerning female
footwear in the workplace activist Yumi
Ishikawa has become the face of a social
movement in Japan and her feet always
shot in flat shoes are not just a
fashion statement
shoes are an expression of Japan's male
chauvinism she said it all comes down to
gender equality taking a page from the
me2 movement Ishikawa and tens of
thousands of followers have declared war
on high heels their campaign is COO -
which means shoe suffering Japan has
been called the land of uniforms for
good reason this nation sartorial
conformity starts early and continues
throughout life
high heels have become part of the dress
code for working women in Japan wearing
them is considered a kind of office
etiquette even Japan's Labour Minister
weighed in calling high heels necessary
and reasonable such was this entrenched
male mindset in Japan that Ishikawa's
old job at a funeral parlor where she
spent six hours a day on her feet heels
were mandatory well things got a three
inch heels were the rule she said when
quitting time rolled around my toes were
bleeding I thought guys do the same job
as me why do they get to wear flat shoes
Ishikawa vented online and Japan felt
her pain literally scores of women
shared war stories about greening and
baring it through blisters back pain and
hammertoes inflicted by prolonged high
heel use the koutou movement was born
demanding the right to comfortable
Footwear at work it's a movement that
seems to have legs
recently major banks Sumitomo Mitsui
abolished formal dress codes a move many
here support
I eat I think heels should be optional
said Kaname kono molto an airline
employee requiring heels makes me wonder
why aren't men wearing them traditional
companies might require heels but not
newer more progressive forms a salary
Kikuchi who works in IT meanwhile
Ishikawa is turning her pain to profit
she's got a new book and is about to
debut her own line of sensible shoes
another step toward Footwear freedom for
CBS this morning Saturday Lucy Kraft
Tokyo interesting mm-hmm well all I have
to say is you know the women of a
certain age your feet have a hard time
in heels not even just a certain age
you're the four negraph inch heels and I
think I'm a woman of a certain age